look at this picture it's a house and a
couple of other things surrounded by a
fence the length of the fence is called
the perimeter it is basically the length
around a closed figure and the region
inside the perimeter is called the area
it is basically the total region
enclosed by a plain figure here the
house the well the haystacks are all on
a rectangular surface covered by a fence
the perimeter is defined as the total
length around the closed figure and the
area is the total region enclosed by a
plain figure this total region inside is
the area and the length of the fence is
the perimeter let us look at a rectangle
it is a shape in which the opposite
sides are equal and parallel these two
sides are equal and parallel these two
sides are also equal and parallel to
each other
adjacent sides uh perpendicular to each
other so all these four angles are right
angles the larger side is called the
length and the smaller side is called
the breadth let us denote the length by
the letter L and the breadth by the
letter B so these two sides are L and
these two sides are P this is a
rectangular plane and is surrounded by
these four sides so this length in red
will be the perimeter it equals L plus B
plus L plus B that equals 2l plus 2 B 2
is a common factor and hence this can be
written as 2 multiplied by L plus B so
if we have a rectangle of length 3
centimeters and breadth two centimeters
then the perimeter would equal 2
multiplied by 3 plus 2 that equals 2
multiplied by 5 which is 10 centimeters
all we did is
substitute the value of length and
breadth here in a similar way we can
find the formula for the perimeter of a
couple of other simple figures we will
cover that next